well a movie of yours that I've seen at
least three times is your first
Hollywood comedy we're the Millers where
you star with Jennifer Aniston and Jason
Sudeikis hysterically funny film at
least one very memorable scene for you
in that one who's talking about there so
yes tell us about this experience of
suddenly being thrust into a into a
Hollywood comedy yeah that was really
interesting that was my first time
actually kind of working so I say away
from home and without any family you
know I was literally the only English
person on set which was kind of strange
and at the time I felt like I was only
English passing in Wilmington North
Carolina which can't have been true but
he felt one quite lonely to be honest
and we're the Millers for as fun as it
was was was really tough I was I was
really lonely out there and I found it
difficult but Jennifer and Jason were
wonderful to me rawson as a director
really fought for me from the beginning
because I think you know in the
marketing campaign it was you know Emma
Roberts Jennifer Aniston Jason Sudeikis
and who the hell is that kid and I
really needed the support of people like
Jason and people like Ross and to kind
of I think to convince the studio that
you know take a shot on this
thank you little English boy and I do
not underestimate what we're the Millers
did for me as far as I think doing other
roles in America and and and having
other opportunities you know made
available to me but for such a sort of
funny you know light-hearted movie it
was it was quite a slog and I think also
I think playing such a kind of
introverted sort of battered awkward's
in many ways sort of self-loathing
character actually had its effect on me
after a while and next you go on to the
Maze Runner 2014 a lot of dystopian teen
movies being made around that at that
time this was one of the the best of
them now when you're in a big franchise
launcher like that
how do you ignore all the bells and
whistles and still find that the
performance and the and the character
talk about challenge you had there
first of all you know and I have to give
massive props to Fox for this they
appointed West Ball as the director and
they didn't necessarily go for a highly
experienced I mean this with no
disrespect to West who says how highly
experienced you know well-known person
Wes up until that point had won the
student Oscar for his phenomenal short
they appointed this young man
effectively to take on this project that
was the mayor on room was potentially
going to be three films and that was so
inspiring and I think he got it purely
based on merit and because he had an
incredible vision for the film and he
had a wonderful grasp of the story and
you know I found myself working with
just this phenomenally talented young
cast an incredibly diverse cast as well
you know all off from different corners
of the world different backgrounds
different ethnicities you know across a
bit of an age range - and it was it was
an absolute blast and you are rewarded
with the BAFTA Rising Star Award what
did that mean to you was it one big
celebration was it daunting you know to
have that responsibility what - what you
remember that time three years ago first
what I'm really grateful for the for the
fact that BAFTA even took notice of what
I was doing I think and and and noticed
me in such a way you know I was hugely
honored by it and I'd seen you know
previous winners which I was a major fan
you know whether it was Tom Hardy or
James McAvoy you know I was I couldn't
believe that I was even nominated for
something that they had won in the past
that was established wild to me you know
and they've gone on to recognize some
fantastic talents you know some friends
of mine are amongst and Jack McConnell
for example being one of them you know
so it's wild to be part of that kind of
little alumni at the time I'm not sure I
really kind of I mean that the night
itself was such a blur you know I like
went with my mom we sat down we had a
nice time next you know they called my
name and I didn't really ever truly
expect that but hugely grateful and it
was a massive confidence booster as well
for me personally you know
to have that support and you go on to
work with another of the the Great's
Leonardo DiCaprio in in the revenant
that still sounds weird to me when you
say that it still sounds weird for me
yeah this your other same poster as
Leonardo DiCaprio now now everything
we've heard about the making of that
movie is sounds like absolutely hellish
and suffering from the arts you know
tell me it was all you know trailers and
cocktails and Peter's or did you really
struggle on that one you know it's it's
funny I mean I'm hesitant to complain
all as an actor who is lucky enough to
work you know first and foremost but if
I may that one was tough that was seven
months either side of a Christmas break
in I mean some of the most remote harsh
unforgiving sort of terrain and
conditions imaginable and you know
emotionally it was tough but but
physically it was outrageous with all
that being said I was working with our
hand Roe Gonzales and are.2 I was
working with the great Emanuel Louie
esky the most insanely talented crew and
a course Leonardo DiCaprio Tom Hardy
domhnall gleeson to name but a few of
the kind of incredible actors that were
part of that project so it was like
toughen up like it was you know there
was no opportunity to kind of complain
or stop it was like this is what it is
and I think for the most part it was
necessary for what we had to to capture
and you know Alejandro is about you know
authenticity and I think you know
throughout his career he's demonstrated
this he's about trying to put the
viewers in the shoes of other people and
make them feel their experience and very
much like Kathryn Bigelow actually you
know they have a wonderful ability to
immerse their actors in
such a wave that elicits a very very
natural performance I think and in turn
makes the viewing experience very
immersive and very natural and real and
you know the opportunity to create
empathy and an understanding that way is
huge
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]